speaking of about that game a lot of
things have happened since we took that
break since you guys conducted that
interview because Fabby had a great
opportunity did he really yes he did he
was close to
winning at this particular moment yes
the he did go with the takes on D5 take
on D5 and D4 very good right and now
Knight to C6 apparently was a big
blunder by Sam Shanklin and Fabiano did
not take um the opportunity
he could have played the move Knight gf5
which is makes a lot of sense right and
that's the thing you have so many Knight
jumps that you can operate with one of
them is Knight G takes uh G you got to
see this follow up for E5 takes D4
that's right you can also go Knight H F5
which is fine as well it kind of have
has the same ideas behind it or uh the
last option Knight to H5 which was the
movie employed by Fabiano okay